-When Barack Obama was
in office,
you received criticism
from the Left.
Now with Trump in office,
you´re receiving criticism
from the Right.
Is part of that
that you don´t believe
it´s your job to parrot
what a President is saying,
and do you feel like right now
we´re seeing a lot
from media figures?
-I feel like -- Yes.
First of all,
our job is to hold
them accountable
and hold them responsible
and point out when they´re lying
and point out when
they say things that can´t
possibly be true,
and be aggressive.
We´re not supposed to be
their friends.
And you know,
it´s pretty simple.
And for eight years, I was not
President Obama´s friend,
and now I´m not
President Trump´s friend.
-Yeah.
-But it´s weird because
a lot of people on the Right
in the media these days...
There are, first of all,
I should point out,
a lot of very
intellectually-honest
conservatives that I see, like,
at "The Weekly Standard,"
at "The National Review."
There are some people on
the Right, and the media Right,
that think it is
somehow rebellious
to be displaying fealty,
and cozying up to power,
to the President,
and it just seems so odd to me,
because that´s --
It wasn´t cool when people on
the Left did that to obama,
and it´s not cool when people
on the Right do it
to President Trump.
-I agree with that.
You also do something that --
We´ve talked about it before
on the show, state of the union,
you also do
"State of the Cartoonian."
-Yes.
-Which is sort of
the week´s news
via cartoons that you draw.
-Yeah, I´m a failed cartoonist.
-You are a failed cartoonist.
-Yeah.
-I did not realize that
cartooning in your younger days
got you in trouble,
in high school.
We tracked down a pretty
good story about you.
-So, let me just preface this
story by saying to my father,
who is watching, I still don´t
think it´s good that I did this.
[ Laughter ]
I understand that
I made a mistake.
So, I was one of the kids
in high school that was kind of
a wise guy.
-Sure.
-And so, you know, they have
those ads in the yearbook,
in the back of the yearbook.
You remember "Mad Magazine" has
the fold in?
-Yeah.
So we had a fold...
-It would be like, yeah...
-Instead of folding it out,
you fold it in,
and so it was this big ad
from the Morgan Stearns
of Wynnewood
congratulating the school
in it´s fortieth year,
and it had "Fortieth Year"
in big letters,
and when you folded it in,
it became an appendage...
that only men have.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And boys.
-Yeah.
-But this was definitely
a man´s, okay?
[ Laughter ]
And it said,
"For all the B.S.,
eat this."
-Wow.
And you managed to do this
in a way that was not --
They did not
recognize it until...
-No, and I had
some co-conspirators.
I did it, and then I had
some co-conspirators
on the yearbook staff
who, like, you know.
-And how quickly
were you found out?
-The day of graduation.
-Yeah, I guess that´s
the safest day to get out.
-But, before we graduated.
-Oh, so that´s not great?
-No.
So we got punished,
and we walked down the aisle.
We got empty naugahyde folders,
and we had to do
community service,
and we had to apologize.
Although, our apology was great.
It was before we even new what a
Washington, D.C. Apology was,
and we wrote one of those.
Like, "I´m sorry if
anybody was offended...
[ Laughter ]
...you delicate creatures."
-I actually saw that apology,
and when you folded that in,
it was also a [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-We thought about that.
-Yeah, that would have been...
Thanks so much
for being here, man.
It´s always such
a pleasure to see you,
and you´ve got
to come back soon.
Jake Tapper, everybody.